الرفيق غونغجو ، الذي أصبح قائدا ، رأى التقدم في بناء أعضاء جون في جيش الشعب.
ينظر إليك بجرأة
أن يكون لديك مثل هذا الجيش المشرف ، المخلص دائمًا ، من الجزء العلوي من الحزب
إنها واحدة من فخر حمام الرأس.
ألم عملاق حزبنا المقلق بدماء وطنه الصادق وولائه ،
من يظن أنه من واجب يديه وعقله أن يعتني بنفسه بعرق
مفترق طرق أكثر صعوبة ، وهو جين 8 جيل ، قائد الفريق الأكثر صرامة ، كان يغريها بفارغ الصبر
كان لذيذا
32 فقط
في غضون خمسة أيام ، تُرك جميع جنود الجيش الشعبي الكوري في نفس الوضع في وسط الغرفة.
الكفوف التفاصيل للنزل
بحلول الذكرى السنوية لتأسيس الحزب بعد ترميم البناء على مستوى صدمة الدولة
أطاح حزبنا الجيش والشعب بإكماله وتسلق خزينة النصر
إنه شعور غير عادي أن قائد فصل التصوير في مدرسته الثانوية متروك لهم.
دون أن يكون على علم
سرعة حرب الإبادة ثلاثية الأبعاد جيدة بالنسبة للبناء ، فأنا أدفع البناء بشدة
جنبا إلى جنب مع متطلبات تصميم تقنية السراويل ، اللجنة المكونة من أربعة أعضاء
بعد عضو مجلس الدولة في جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية ، تولى خان موري الإدارة العليا المشتركة
حشد تشون دو هوان والبحارة المشردون من وحدة الجيش الشعبي للإطاحة بخو
مع مراعاة الرطوبة ، غمرت العديد من الحقول في التربة السطحية للأرز في منطقة صغيرة
ما رأيك في حدوث مرض الباذنجان وصعوبة تركيب الصدمات لمن يلعب؟
الرفيق القائد الأعلى للخادم ،
هناك خيط استعرته ، لكن في الربيع والصيف ، أجمع العرق الذي فقدته الموارد الزراعية
لتقليل حكمة المحاصيل التي اكتسبتها بشق الأنفس وزيادة الغلة
حتى النهاية ، يجب خوض هذه المعركة ذات المسؤولية الضعيفة حتى النهاية
انت فعلت
هناك أيضًا مخاوف وشكاوى سمعت عنها ، لكنها قوة عظيمة للتفكير فيها مرة أخرى.
احتضانًا لاستخدام الفجل الذي لا مثيل له ، سيكون حفلنا مجانيًا ، 4 أمتار
مقابل سماء التثبيت السهل الذي تمت كتابته في جميع أنحاء العالم
إرادة